are you an indica or a sativa smoker
um
primarily indica but you know i i've
been doing a lot of exotics and hybrids
these days you know so it's a mix
sort of both sometimes
indica dominant sometimes sativa
dominant
um before a show
oh yeah
no no obviously but before show indica
it doesn't matter do you have a specific
weed before show it doesn't matter what
it is for us it's you know like as long
as it tastes good and the impact is
there
you know we'll smoke it before the show
whether it's indica or sativa primarily
we always smoked indicas because we used
to be snobs about every other
strain if it wasn't cush o.g kush the
real og kush um if it wasn't that we
wouldn't even [ __ ] with you you know i'm
like ah no hold it we'll we'll smoke
some of ours with you
you keep your [ __ ]
it wasn't until um
i'm going to say
maybe 10 years ago that i started
smoking other flavors outside of og
because you know one of my good friends
we had run out of weed in san francisco
on this tour but i knew there was wheat
out there but there's no we could never
find any good og out there everything
else bomb but you could never find some
og like southern california og out there
so i called one of my boys jp from west
coast cure i said hey
we need something we rent we just ran
out what do you got oh i got tahoe og i
got platinum cookies i got this that i
said you know what let me try those
platinum cookies i've been hearing about
these platinum cookies or just cookies
for the last six months at the time
and he was like i got you no sweat
and he brought it rolled it up and boom
i was like oh [ __ ] this is really good
and that opened my my palate up to start
smoking different [ __ ] other than og so
like i started smoking all sorts of
different strains out there and then
the flavor boom happened where
everybody's developing different flavors
different exotics different crosses and
[ __ ] like that and to me that's great
because i mean we like options it's like
if you just had one drink would you be
happy with that yeah it's called stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and if you
go on amazon and type in stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude